pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh oh oh oh oh
des alpes à la côte d'azur d'embrun
avant ton le chef de l'état a rencontré
un accueil enthousiaste qui devait de
sites et inciter au milieu des foules de
tous les âges répéter celui de gap
[Applaudissements]
sur la route des rencontres inédites
comme celle de ces deux couples de
jeunes mariés que le général s'est
arrêté pour complimenter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès son premier discours le général de
gaulle avait évoqué l'algérie la p17 il
est devant la porte à cannes plus à 10
ils devaient être plus nette encore et
dénoncer l'intervention d'un certaine
empire qui prétend intervenir dans la
solution du problème
c'est l'histoire de tartuffe qui se
faisait le champion de la vertu mais
nice ce devait être aussi la visite d'un
homme à l'éternel cigare winston
churchill et c'était monaco où le
drapeau français flotter sur le palais
pour la première fois depuis 1931 date
de la visite du président doumergue
monaco ou sous la conduite du commandant
cousteau le prince rainier la princesse
grace ont fait à leurs hôtes les
honneurs du célèbre musée
océanographique qui n'a sont égales
nulle part dans le monde et dont on
projette encore l'extension
[Musique]
48 mille tonnes c'est le port en lourd
comme on dit du dernier né des chantiers
de dunkerque où monsieur robert buron
ministre des travaux publics est venu
présider à son lancement
lancé par les pétrole bp ce super
pétrolier dont le nom évoque rassure les
maires l'un des prestigieux châteaux de
la loire
amboise a une capacité de soixante trois
mille mètres cubes mais il sera aussi
l'un des pétroliers les plus luxueux et
son équipage il disposera entre autres
confort d'une piscine
homo
45 millions de français ce qui fait 90
millions de pieds qui circulent chaque
jour en france qui est enfantin encore à
certains qui ont besoin qu'on les guides
qui est plus assurée en bon ordre
gaillard et conquérant pied aussi qu'ils
savent se faire remarquer dans la foule
anonyme
tantôt en s'élevant délibérément au
dessus des autres
tantôt au contraire empêchant par
modestie pied encore dont l'élégance
justement et de passer inaperçu
et bien tout ne va pas pour le mieux
dans ce monde un peu oubliée au ras du
sol
les statistiques sont formelles les
médecins ont trop de pied à soigner
songez à ce que vous avez pu faire de
vos charmants pieds de bébé trop d'à
luxe valgus on entendit d'oignons dûs à
l'abus de chaussures et 3 des chaussures
trop courte et ce sont des orteils en
marteau des chaussures pointues encore
en traîne souvent le chevauchement
autre danger les pieds plats n'attendez
pas d'être acculé à l'opération soignez
vos pieds
détendez les parts des bains fréquents
songez qu'ils sont enfermés plus de 12
heures sur 24 et puis sachez choisir
avec discernement leur prison
rien d'important pour éviter les
déformations comme de savoir trouver les
chaussures les mieux adaptés rien de
dangereux comme les souliers à tige
rigide pour les enfants en pleine
formation osseuse leurs pieds ne doivent
pas subir de contraintes
pas de chaussures trop étroites
messieurs l'ongle incarné c'est la
plupart du temps l'intervention
chirurgicale nécessaire
et vous mesdames pas de talons trop ce
genre d'élégance vous menace d'une
déformation de la colonne vertébrale pas
de talons trop plat non plus qui a fait
cela voûte plantaire adopté le juste
milieu
comme le reste du corps les pieds
doivent respirer penser à les aérer et
puis dites vous que les pieds ne sont
pas constamment voué aux tâches ingrates
le charme ne leur est pas un domaine
interdite
en somme un minimum de respect s'impose
pour les vôtres comme pour les pieds d
[Musique]
à 85 ans pablo casals eux demeure fidèle
à la musique et pour ce rendez vous de
travail avec iphone il a abandonné le
violoncelle pour la baguette du chef
d'orchestre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
habitués que nous sommes au record on
admirera cependant celui que représente
la vitalité du plus célèbre
violoncelliste du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
le violoncelliste c'est aujourd'hui
maurice gendron désigné par le maître de
prades comme son continuateur nec pour
notre joie pablo casals chef d'orchestre
n'a pas dit adieu à pablo casals le plus
merveilleux violoncelliste de l'époque
[Musique]
à victoria station l'arrivée du roi du
népal qui était venu accueillir la reine
elizabeth et le duc d'edimbourg
accompagné des membres de la famille
royale d'angleterre a déclenché une
série de révérence et autres politesse
[Musique]
réflexe conditionné pourrait-on dire
auquel semble maintenant parfaitement
rompus le mari de margaret
on ignore sans doute que les liens qui
unissent l'angleterre et le népal date
de 150 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le panchen lama qui est depuis l'exil
forcé du dalaï lama la principale
autorité du cube et s'est rendu en
visite à pékin donc on sait les rapports
serré avec l'aca depuis l'occupation
chinois at on a usé à cette occasion de
la forme traditionnelle de la bienvenue
tibétaine les changes des écharpes dans
lequel il ne faut pas voir d'autre
signification que celle que comportent
les révérences occidental
c'est dans une atmosphère étouffante que
s'est ouvert dans un ancien gymnase de
l'île de yas siadat au large de ce qu
tahri le procès de monsieur même des
rays chefs de l'ex gouvernement turc est
de près de 400 notabilité de l'ancien
régime
on sait que monsieur menderes est
passible de la peine de mort ainsi que
l'ex président de la république monsieur
djellal bayard
[Musique]
les flèches noires c'est leur nom ne
sont pas si connue ici qu en angleterre
où elle forme l'escadrille acrobatique
de la royal air force
depuis quatre années qu'elles se
manifestent leur audace et leur
performance ont fait trembler des
millions de spectateurs
or le règne des flèches noires se
termine et nous assistons à l'une de
leurs dernières manifestations le ping
tonneau vol de groupes chassé-croisé
dispersion les flèches noires se livrer
à ces petites fantaisies sans erreur
comme sans effort à 8 100 à l'heure
les flèches noires vont donc disparaît
mais qu'on se rassure le ciel de la ra f
ne demeurera pas vite
on verra bientôt d'autres flèches noires
[Musique]